de croire que les gens pourraient
embarquer dans un système comme ça puis
essayer de pas conduire quand ils sont
ils ont pris de l'alcool je sais pas si
la population embarque crudence
de trouver un volontaire qui boit pas
qui qui boit pas qui conduit
la population a effectivement adopté le
projet et des bénévoles et bien ils en
ont trouvé en 1984 la première opération
Nez rouge est lancé dans la ville de
Québec avec la collaboration du service
de police
Opération Nez rouge bonsoir Jean-Marie
deconnec professeur de mathématiques à
l'Université Laval et aussi entraîneur
de natation à l'idée de reconduire des
Québécois qui ont pris un verre de trop
dans leur propre voiture pendant les
fesses il demande donc à ses nageurs de
servir de conducteur
dès la première année ils effectuent 463
accompagnements il accumule des dons de
20 000 dollars tout un succès
du lait pour l'opération des rouges qui
sont en direction l'opération est rouge
a changé les mentalités sur la question
de l'alcool au volant parce que si vous
qui allez causer l'accident possible
c'est vous qui allez peut-être briser un
foyer parce que vous n'êtes pas assez
prudent ou assez intelligent pour
appeler nez rouge le nombre d'accidents
mortels causés par l'alcool sont trop
fréquents on est en train d'effectuer
une opérationnel
est-ce que vous avez consommé la boisson
à la galette ce soir
l'opération prend alors de l'expansion
plusieurs villes québécoises emboîtent
le pas en 1987 le nombre d'organismes
qui offrent le service de
raccompagnement passe de 6 à 12 il y a
15 ans quand dans un parquet quand
quelqu'un est en état de boisson on
disait une chance que sa voiture pour
rentrer chez lui il serait même pas de
marcher puis on trouvait ça drôle fort
heureusement les habitudes ont bien
changé et cette belle idée c'est
propagée
en 2019 l'opération nerouge rejoint 61
communautés au Québec
et sans une au Canada ça fait des petits
un peu partout en Europe surtout en
Suisse
chaque année je me réjouis de faire des
rouges parce qu'on est vraiment une
bonne équipe une bonne bande comme on
dit en raison de la pandémie l'opération
des rouges a considérablement réduit ses
activités en 2020 2021 mais cette année
tout revient à la normale mais là on
revient en force il semble avoir un
intérêt important de la part de la
communauté des restaurateurs et tout et
aussi des bénévoles dans chacune des
communautés les sommes recueillis
servent aussi à financer de nombreux
activités pour les jeunes au Québec
aujourd'hui
c'est une centaine d'organismes à vue
non lucratifs qui organise l'opération
des routes sur leur territoire et qui
profitent totalement des retombées
financières de l'opération des rouges
mais avant tout faut pas l'oublier
l'Opération Nez rouge contribue à sauver
des vies
ici Jacques Bissonnière Radio-Canada
Montréal